non ça va ma chérie qu'est ce que je
suis alors ça y est vous êtes enceinte
de combien de gym banni de son
plaisir ou l'adorent je les ai toujours
aimé mais c'est vrai je suis heureux de
te vois moi c'est en fait voilà quand
même addition scène tu dois bien
d'autres
je suis fauché dialogue et une
fille et un garçon c'est pas moi je
pense est une fille ouais on lance un
peu le parent et bah si c'est une fille
eh ben vous serez parent c'est un garçon
je serai petit garçon bas qui me connais
qu'un salon
le parrain c'est quoi ce il paraît que
c'est celui qui doit récupérer des
enfants s'y tiendra
je serais ravi que imaginer le gac et
parrain des anges en castaldi il sera
quoi avec une classe de 4e degré chez
lui avec ça c'est vrai c'est que c'est
une fille je le sens